You probably know Luigi as the most famous
sidekick in gaming history.
A second fiddle.
The guy who's always destined to be Player
2.
Luigi spends so much time in his older brother's
shadow, it's easy to forget that he's a fully
fledged character on his own.
And, depending on the media he's appearing
in, not a particularly nice one.
Here's a look at the most terrible things
Luigi has ever done.
Just in it for the cash
In 1986, Nintendo and Grouper Studios released
an hour-long anime produced to promote the
Japanese release of Super Mario Bros. 2, later
known to American gamers as The Lost Levels.
While the movie is a reasonably faithful adaptation
of the first couple Mario games, there's one
big difference: in the film, Luigi is the
absolute worst, and we're not just talking
about his bizarrely mis-colored costume.
While Mario's motives are noble, Luigi only
agrees to join him on the quest after being
promised all the gold coins they find on the
adventure.
As a result, he spends the whole cartoon greedily
searching for gold, even at the risk of his
friends' lives.
This version of Luigi isn't just greedy, either.
While tripping on mushrooms, he punches Mario
in the face.
And when the group runs low on food, Luigi
even thinks about eating Kibidango, the Mario
Bros.' dog-like companion.
Yikes, dude.
Mad with power
Over in Germany, gamers were treated to Club
Nintendo, a magazine filled with absolutely
insane comic strips.
One of the most jarring is Super Mario: In
the Flush of Speed, where Luigi becomes a
cop and uses his newfound authority to make
Mario's life a living hell.
First, he pulls Mario over for going too fast
— apparently, when he's riding Yoshi down
the city streets, Mario needs to obey all
the regular traffic laws.
Next, Luigi scolds Mario for referring to
him as Luigi and not "Officer Luigi," as befits
his new position.
Finally, when Mario hops off Yoshi's back
by spin-jumping — which, let's remember,
is the only way to dismount the dinosaur in
Super Mario World — Luigi informs his brother
that spin-jumps are strictly prohibited between
1 and 3 p.m.
And while Luigi's a stickler for the rules,
he's not corrupt: he fines Mario — his own
brother — 60 coins for his transgressions.
That's right: family means nothing in Officer
Luigi's totalitarian dystopia.
All talk
In Paper Mario: The Thousand-Year Door, Luigi
is revealed to be a lying blowhard, as it
turns out all the supposed adventures he boasts
about throughout the game are complete fiction.
For example , Luigi says that, in order to
defeat a monster, Luigi threw the squid-like
Blooper named Blooey at the boss' weak spot.
According to Blooey, that's true, but Luigi
conveniently leaves out the part where he
missed, sending Blooey flying into a puddle
of lava.
Even worse, the general public actually buys
his propaganda, as books based on Luigi's
adventures begin appearing in the game.
Though, given how little credit he gets for
his real adventures, it's hard to blame him.
Totally uninhibited
In Super Paper Mario, Luigi isn't just comedic
relief — he's also the game's main villain.
According to the Dark Prognosticus, a book
of prophecies written by an unknown author,
the "man in green" is the perfect host for
the Chaos Heart, which will destroy the world.
That man in green is, of course, Luigi.
After being captured by the master hypnotist
Nastasia, Luigi's inhibitions are released
and he becomes the sinister Mr. L. Openly
jealous of Mario's abilities, Mr. L teams
up with a new robot buddy and spends the game
attacking Mario.
He even makes a move on Princess Peach!
And that's even before the mercenary Dimentio
fuses with Luigi and tries to bring about
the end of the world using the Chaos Heart.
So was it all mind control?
Or did the bad guys just unleash Luigi's true
feelings?
All we can say for sure is: watch your back,
Mario.
Fraternal abuse
Most of the time, Luigi's love-hate relationship
with his brother ends up coming across as
passive-aggressive.
But in Mario and Luigi: Bowser's Inside Story,
there's nothing passive about it.
Early in the game, both brothers get hammers,
which they can use in combat and to solve
puzzles.
While Mario uses his hammer in reasonable
ways, like destroying obstacles that block
his path, Luigi uses his to beat on his older
brother.
Pummeling Mario is the only way to proceed
in the game, but you better believe it hurts.
One of the main reasons to use Luigi's hammer
is to transform Mario into Mini-Mario — y'know,
the form Mario takes when he's damaged by
an enemy, leaving him unable to break bricks
and teetering on the brink of death.
But hey, it also allows Mario to pass through
small passages, so why not gamble with your
brother's life?
Looks like Luigi is working out some serious
issues here.
Tellingly, Luigi doesn't even flinch when
he learns he has to hit Mario on the head.
That's not a loving brother.
That's a cold-hearted menace.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!